In the last video we achieved a lot
Understanding how vector functions work
or the position of a vector function, which
is in some sense a substitution of the traditional one
parameterization when describing curves
And what I want to do in this video is to give a little more
a sense of what it takes to get a derivative of
a vector function.
In this case, this will be in relation to the parameter t
So, let me draw a new coordinate system here.
Let us say that we have the vector function r (t)
and it is no different than the one I did in the previous video.
r (t) = X (t) .i + Y (t) .j
If we do this in 3 dimensions, then we will add z (t) .k
but let us keep things relatively simple and let them
let's say this describes the curve, and let's say the curve
with which we work t is between a and b and this curve
will look like something like that, let me do my best to draw
curve. I will draw some approximate curve here, and so on
let's say the curve looks like this.
It is when t = a, and it starts to
moves in that direction.
This is when t = b - right here, it is t = a
and right here will be x (a), and here is y (a)
and analogously here above is x (b) and
this is y (b) here.
-
In the previous video we see that the endpoints of these
radius vectors are what describes the curve trays
So, in the previous video we saw that r from a
describes this point here
I do not want to go back to that in detail
I now want to think about what the difference is
between 2 points?
Let me take a random point here
Somehow by accident
Let's call this r of t
In fact, I will take another point,
because I want to be a little clearer
I will change with another color - let's say this here
is r at some point t
t is here
and this is r of t
This will be a positive value to us
Thus, this is our specific point t
Now let's say we increase t
with little
with h
Let's say r from t plus h ... well, if we look at it
the parameter t as time, we moved forward in time
and our little particle has moved
a little
And let's say we're here
This here in yellow is r of t plus h
Just a slightly higher value of h
One question we can ask now is: how much
is fast changing f in terms of t?
First we have to say: what is it
the difference between this is this?
I want to imagine this
If we take r, the radius vector we get
by calculating the radius at t plus h; from this
I will pull r from t
-
And what do we get?
Here you can negotiate algebra with vectors, but
we will get this vector
Let me take a nice, bright color
We will get this vector here
So, this purple vector here, let's draw it,
is the vector r of t
plus h minus r of t
And this should be logical for you because when
we collect vectors, heads go to tails
The other option is to write this as r from t plus
this here, plus r of t plus h minus r of t
Here's what happens when we collect vectors, let's
clarify, I add this vector
to this vector here
We put the tail of the second vector
to the head of the first
So, this is our first vector and I put the tail
the second here. Now, the sum of these two vectors as well
assumed, is equal to this vector
It is equal to r of t plus h
You will now see, in algebraic logic,
that this is it will be canceled
-
I hope this comes as an explanation
I want to be clear
Suddenly, this is no longer a radius vector
We do not say: let's put the tail of this vector
at the beginning and use this vector to describe one
This is now a kind of pure vector
He simply describes the change between two
other radius vectors
-
This vector literally describes the change
But let us think what kind of algebraic kind this is
if we extend it this way
This will be equal to, what is r of t plus h?
Let me write it here. This is the same
such as x of t plus h on the single vector
and plus y of t plus h on the single vector j,
this part here, minus that part,
minus ... I'll do this on the second line,
I could do it here too, but it ends my place
Minus x of t, r of t is just x of t in i, plus ... but here
will divide the minus sign, so it is minus
y from t j
Actually, let me write it this way,
this is a minus, plus that
To see that this is the same here
like this
I just count for t
So, we have x from t and t and then we can
to distribute, right?
If you assign this minus sign, we get minus x
of t and min y from t
Here we have vectors collection - maybe you need to
negotiating this if you have not been to him for a long time
You know you can just collect the relevant components
You can collect x-components and y-components
-
This will be equal to ... let me transcribe it here
because I think I will need a place
Let me transcribe it here
So, I have r of t plus x minus r of t is equal ... and now
I will simply group the x and y components - this is equal to
x components collected together, but this is us
negatively, then we'll get that out
from this
So, x from t plus h minus x from t, all this under
our single vector in x direction. And then we have plus y from t
plus h minus y of t on a single vector in the j direction
Here I just rearrange to find out what
is the difference between every two r for a given
change in distance
And our change in the distance here is h between everyone
two radius vectors
What I was about to show you
in this video is how to find change
and now we are working on the momentary change
with respect to t
I want to find out how much this has changed
for a period of h
Instead of h we could write the delta t
and that would not change anything
So I want to divide this into h
I mean, it's a h
-
This is the same as when dealing with the slope
We have a lift on the track, on the delta y, or
the change in y on the change in x
This is like the change in our change function in x
Let's divide everything. Maybe you should not
I say change in x, but change in t
Here, our change in t is h, huh?
The difference between t plus h and t will be just h
So we will divide everything into h
When we multiply a vector by scalar or divisible
scalar value, we just take each of the components
vector and multiply or divide the scalar value
And that's what we get
So, for the ending difference h, this
this shows us how much the vector for h is changing
But if we want to find the momentary change,
as we did when we first learned about
differential calculations, here's what we will do
This is analogous to bills of gradient
That would do us a good job if that one
the trajectory was such
If it was a linear trajectory
and it looked like this
Then we could just make a plan and get it
the average change in radius vectors you can imagine -
two radius vectors and this is one of them
In fact, they were all parallel in this case
But it is not mandatory for the radius vectors to be parallel
They could look like this
And then, that would simply describe the change between
these two vectors for h or how quickly these radius vectors
are changing for the change in our parameter. No?
This is h or, if you prefer, delta t
Some people find h for easier,
others - delta t
Anyway, I'm interested in the momentary change
We have curves and we have high math
It would be good if we had only algebraic,
linear world
So what do we do?
Let me move
Let's take that boundary. I want to take a nice color,
but my colors are over
The boundary when h is approaching 0 on both sides
Here, too, will take the boundary when h approaches 0
and here too will take the border when
h is approaching 0
Here I mean how much change we have
to change the parameter t, but also what it is
the momentary change when the difference happens
becoming smaller and smaller?
That's what we learned when we were dealing with
momentary slope or instantaneous speed, or
slope of tangent line
That seems to me indefinite at the moment
For functions with vector values ​​we have no limits
and certain derivatives
But fortunately, all of us
looks familiar
This is in fact the definition of our derivative
If this is a scalar function
They are multiplied by vectors to get
functions with vector values
But here, by definition, we are the derivative
This is x of t
Or, this is dx dt
This here is the primacy of t, or we can
to record it as dy dt
So, this is not really indefinite
My explanations are a bit cumbersome, but here
I just want to motivate your intuition
We can call this expression
the derivative of the vector function r
with regard to t, or we can call it dr dt
Note that I have left the signs for a vector
This is the derivative of t and, as such,
will be just equal to the derivative of x
x with respect to t, which is equal to
x the t of the single vector x, the horizontal
single vector, plus y of t, by the single vector y, by
j, the single vector in the horizontal direction
This is a pretty good result
But perhaps the hard part is to imagine
visually what it means
Let me draw a great graphics for
for you can visualize this better
Let my curve be something like this
This is my curve
And let's say we're looking for the moment
change this point
So it's r of t
And then we take r from t plus h, we have already seen that
t plus h may be something like this
So this is r of t plus h
Now, the difference between the two ...
this is the numerator when we take the difference
How fast is the change from this vector to this vector
in terms of t? I know it's hard to visualize that
I will write a whole clip to pay more attention
This may be a vector
So, the difference between these two things
this will be ours
But then, when we divide into h, it will get bigger
vector, yes - assuming h is a small number
Let's say h is less than 1
We will get a larger vector, right?
But this is kind of the average change for that time
But when h gets less and less, that
The r of t will take a tangent direction
this curve
You can imagine that, do not you?
These two vectors are getting closer together
dr decreases or the difference between these
two delta r gets smaller
You can imagine if h was even less if he was here
Suddenly, the difference between these two vectors
is becoming smaller
And more and more tangential to this curve
-
But we also divide into less h, meaning the derivative,
the boundary when h approaches 0 can
even if it is a bigger number
In fact, it's a little difficult to imagine
the size of this vector
It will depend on the parameterization of the curve
It does not depend on the shape of the curve
The direction of this vector depends on the shape of this vector
curve and that direction will be
tangent to the curve
You can also imagine this vector
is on the tangent line of this curve
The magnitude of the vector is more difficult to understand
The next video will try to
I give you some intuition about her
But that's what I want you to understand now,
because we will be able to use it in the future when
we deal with linear vector vector integration
-